foreign
so my opinion is the traditionalism is
kind of out the window
um
if
if modern women want traditional guys
they're gonna have to take on
traditional roles
it's it comes down to that
if modern women want traditional guys
they have to take on traditional roles
do you see that happening
I don't not in this climate especially
politically
um
yeah I think the political correctness
is just wreak havoc on the nuclear
family in general it's taking the balls
away from every guy in his house for the
most part
um yeah it's just there's a lack of
respect in the houses now
so with that being said what is the
solution for men going forward do you
think they should spin plates for a
lifetime do you think they should live
together no legal marriage
so I I can't speak for everybody
everybody's situation is different
um my situation is unique in its own um
I'm with a woman who's got two kids
prior to me
um I ended up having a kid with her as
well
but knowing that
um she's going through some things on
you know as everybody does and yeah
everybody's situation is different so
you really can't just make a blanket a
blanket thing that's going to work for
everybody
did you get married or no
no I and I refuse to she wants to
um and we we butt heads because every
time one of her friends gets married off
you know it turns into a big fight in my
house so
um but yeah I mean I've just put my foot
down when she got divorced the last time
she was kicked out of her house
um with the kids and I just you know
everybody has their past
um but I don't see a need to make the
kids suffer for that so we've I
basically set it up to where she could
she was able to purchase this house and
her name with my income
um she set up no matter what happens as
far as me and her are concerned
um
yes that's just where I'm at I'm not
going to get married though I don't see
any benefit in it and if I if I don't
have to stay illegally you know because
marriage is just a contract if I don't
have to stay legally and I do shouldn't
that mean more to somebody
yeah oh that's interesting yeah probably
she could
I think I think the way like women look
at it
is
I don't know we're always going to want
to get married but like I also really
see the men's point of view where it's
like what incentive do you guys have to
do that nowadays
I mean he was married and I was married
uh I was in the military and anybody
who's in the military knows getting
married is calming
you know even in my my family's history
that my parents didn't stay together
most of the most of the my cousins my
Aunts Uncles they've all split up so
just from my experience what I've
witnessed it's just there's no point to
it
do you think people stay together longer
if they don't get married just not data
or anything just personal experience
I'm saying I'm sorry sir do you think
people
um state that you know stay together
longer if they're not married not data
or anything just personal experience do
the people that are just dating seem
happier than the married people that you
know I'm just curious the comparison
yeah I mean that's a good question I
don't think I've ever really thought of
that
um
I would say there's not as much stress
on the guy's side
if it's not continuously pushed on him
like if a guy wants to get married he's
going to get married he's going to ask
you
um that's kind of the last bit of
control we have in this in the matter
what do you think we can't we can't tell
them not to have a kid like I had I've
got a two-year-old now and I wouldn't
change it for anything because it
changes your world but I didn't want
kids coming into this
so it's like she took that option away
from me and I'm not being spiteful
because this was my decision from the
beginning whether I had a child with her
or not I'm just not getting married
again
what do you think of women
um giving men ultimatums because
something that I heard from Kevin
Samuels was you shouldn't date a guy
longer than say a year if he doesn't if
you want to be married
um the goat yeah yeah and you always
hear the if he wanted to he would marry
you if he really loved you he would
marry you but it's like from what I've
seen I see a lot of guys date girls for
a long period of time and I really do
think they love them and want to be with
them but it just seems like marriage
isn't in their best interest so what do
you what do you think of that
I think you kind of nailed it on the
head I think that's kind of what it is
there's just really no benefit for the
guy anymore I mean at this point for for
my particular situation
I mean how much is it is a wedding we're
gonna take that off of your table here I
mean we we're not we're living together
we're basically married thank God I live
in this state because there's no common
law
um otherwise I that would be a thing
eventually that I could get myself into
some legal issues later on if we did
split so really I think it's more guys
are just trying to protect themselves
for as long as they can
what if your girl said um I just want to
be your wife I don't care about the
wedding would you do it then or no
all right so this is my particular
situation she's not a woman of Christ
you know we've had a child out of
wedlock she was married before what are
you getting at like what for who
that's funny
does that make sense yeah no I mean she
wants to go and she wants to go to the
courthouse and change her last name go
for it
oh that's funny not a woman of Christ
okay thank you for calling in I
appreciate it
all right thanks have a good one not a
woman and crying
um
okay okay I'll tell them guys so
um when when you call in when I'm on the
phone we can't answer it so you have to
wait till we're done is that the beeping
is in the background I see so so in
order this we're we're new to the live
show Colin so in order to make this the
highest quality show possible
please call after he hangs up
after after we hang up okay I know I
know it's hard to get on the phone so
like you want to keep calling but just
do it after they hang up okay you can
take the next you can call now take the
next caller
it's interesting though because
oh is are they on okay okay hello this
is Pearl you're live on the air
April this is AJ how you doing today I'm
good how are you
good good good yes uh I was uh I love
you your show it's great the Topic's
awesome but I really don't think really
men need need to do much on our end
because if you see the eviction rates in
the US with seriously black women are up
and through the roof and now Generation
X is uh the biggest group of women that
either didn't get married didn't have
kids or their kids are are grown so now
you're starting to see homeless homeless
women out there in the streets so
marriage has always been the retirement
plan or economic stability so this is
the first time where you go to
California San Francisco Seattle you see
women in these homeless camps you know
so what's going to happen is that if
there's another big uh you know uh
variant of the you know of the bug or
whatever or any type of economic
downturn when women are doing well men
are doing just fine so as far as as
marriage goes I really think that
especially in the west all of our
countries are very reactive and not
proactive and it's going to take
something like people's basic needs not
getting met women are going to really
need to start because because that's one
thing that I feel that a lot of the
women who are on your show don't get is
they always go oh Pearl women are are
doing it and we're only six percent
the women in the United States earned
six figures most women the number one
employer the women is retail so women
are not doing it they're not out earning
men they're not outpacing men they're
not doing well at all and with this
Automation and and retail stores
clothing women are out on the streets so
I really think so what do you think that
the solution is for women then moving
forward do you think they
because it's interesting because
a lot of times they'll push getting
married but at the same time tell men
not to
well I think that on women's they need
to understand the Practical benefits to
get married and stay married and then
men need to just like how women try and
withhold sex uh
because they have high standards men
need to make our standards higher for
for marriage okay so for instance you
know go ahead I'm more on the left but I
always tell all of my friends uh dating
us change your your settings to
conservative or find a woman who's from
overseas who has who meets a certain
checklist of of morals and standards if
you're going to choose to marry it at
all you know but you have to as a man
treat your last name like a woman's
supposed to treat her vagina you know
you have to have standards the same
thing so what do you
um
what do you want to get married
some yeah okay would you get married
legally
well the thing is is is this
it depends on the state and it depends
on who you're married to right because
so say say dream girl dream girl every
every check box is checked
huh every box is checked
yeah you would get married legally yes
or no
yes but in Texas
okay Texas are like Wyoming or something
you know what I'm saying okay because
like the maximum amount of child support
that you have to pay in tax in Texas is
like eighteen hundred dollars or
something like like twenty three hundred
dollars even if if you're some oil
billionaire like Texas I think that
Missouri have it sorted where like
it's really hard well I mean men can
still get screwed over but you get like
the least amount of screwed over in a
lot of red States I I grew up on the
west coast but I honestly think that I'm
gonna have to to move to like the
reddest the red state by the way that
things are going now okay so crazy how
long would you date a girl before
getting married
um
maybe about a year that depends on your
age if you're in your 20s right then I
would say that it takes a little while
to kind of get to know someone uh and
then also you need to kind of have those
life altering events so for instance you
might have to move or do something and
then you kind of see if the person is
that one to be with if you're more in
your 40s or 50s and you're just trying
to move on in life you should probably
know what you want already the 30s it
all depends on if it's like a single mom
which I recommend not dating or
I'm wearing at all but the older that
you get the less time so so older about
a year older about a year it sounds like
about about a year less if you're older
okay okay so um Your solution is to get
married in a conservative state
uh yeah if if you choose to marry if you
first of all it's really most guys I
really think in the west don't get
married but if you choose to because you
want to have kids move to the reddest of
the red state
or uh uh a conservative traditional
chick or a chick who's from an
international I mean country like you
know South America a Muslim woman or
something or any community that has
shame and a stigma for divorce and I
think you'll be all right okay okay
thank you for calling as many of you
know I was just banned on Tick Tock and
we are demonetized on a daily basis on
this platform if you want to help please
consider sending a super thanks below
every donation helps and it helps make
what we do possible